bonjour eric zemmour au jour plusieurs
députés la république en marche viennent
de créer leur propre groupe
parlementaire et vous y voyez un retour
du bon vieux clivage droite gauche
d'abord ça a un effet mécanique et qui
n'est pas négligeable après tout c'est
que ça prive le groupe en marche de la
majorité absolue donc ils vont être
obligés de tenir compte davantage de
leurs alliés modem ccc pas fondamental
ça va pas vous voyez c'est pas cccc ça
va pas changer la face de dieu du régime
ni du quinquennat mais quand même c'est
un fait il en plus
effectivement comme vous dites ces
députés l'addon voir lien tâche et on
voit delphine batho c'est des gens qui
viennent du ps et qui ne veulent pas y
retourner mais c'est des gens de gauche
et qui considèrent qu'il y à une dérive
droitière du mandat de macron depuis le
son élection en 2007 donc qui veulent un
préfère un pôle de gauche et kikititi
veulent donc notre souhait d'autonomie
c'est le retour des frondeurs mais avec
moins d'effets évidemment destructeur
sur le quinquennat
alors vous poser la bonne question est
ce que c'est le retour du clivage droite
gauche
en tout cas ces gens là se sont toujours
considérés de gauche et ont toujours
considéré qu emmanuel macron était un
des leurs c'est à dire c'est mais c'est
une gauche moderne c'est à dire que là
c'est ce qu'on appelle par la gauche
depuis 68 c'est à dire c'est des
internationalistes cd francs sans
frontiérisme cd immigrationniste il
critique la laïcité et ils sont
féministes et ils sont et ça c'est la
gauche telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'est à dire le contraire de la gauche
républicaine dias en temps mais mais
passons de l'autre côté d'ailleurs on
pourrait dire qu'on a remarqué pendant
ce confinement
j'ai pas si vous avez remarqué que les
hiérarques de l est non seulement été
très timide voire un conte un con c'est
vraiment un conséquent est en tout cas
un 10 et comment dire complètement
évanescent est ce que c'est parce que
finalement ils sont d'accord avec la
gestion quand on a fait le premier
ministre edouard philippe qui vient de
leur rang j'allais vous tire justement
c'est même plus que ça d'après moi vous
avez remarqué que les rares
interventions à part peut-être les
présidents de groupe
retailleau sénat abad à l'assemblée qui
était un peu plus de pub menace mais
sinon il ne pouvait pas s'empêcher je
parle des dix chefs du parti un bon chat
comme on l'a pas entendu apparemment il
a été malade mais même baroin ne pouvait
pas s'empêcher de faire un éloge
d'edouard philippe comme par contraste
bien sûr avec une petite critique
discrète de macron mais je crois que
c'est plus que de la tactique
après tout edouard philippe est un des
leurs c'est un juppéiste qui en a
rajouté dans la filiation du pays cela
pendant ce confinement est un mélange de
droit dans ses bottes et de fausse
humilité et d'ennui et en gros c'était
ça il doit finir il a très bien fait et
le et le plr était en extase parce qu'on
fait l air qu est ce que c'est c'est des
notables locaux des grands notables
locaux modéré lr est devenu un parti
centriste et donc edouard philippe qui
est le premier ministre d'emmanuel mâcon
est un centre droit donc tous ces gens
là se reconnaît soyez c'est alors c'est
assez amusant parce que le retour du
clivage droite gauche oui mais dans un
cadre hyper restreint avec une gauche
mondialiste voiliers et progressistes et
une droite je dirais techno techno
libéral bon alors finalement entre une
fausse gauche et une fausse droite
qu'est-ce qui pourrait réconcilier les
français avec la politique
ben je pense qu'effectivement évidemment
ccc encore en gestation tout ça il faut
être honnête mais je pense que les
électeurs et en particulier les
électeurs des classes populaires se
moque de tous ces positionnements et ne
ça ne leur parle plus c'est fini ces
gens là sont des astres mort qui parle à
des catégories sociales très très
restreint merci eric zemmour